it is really great to be here at the
Royal Andrew a Royal Harry nice
that's rebel Wilson roasting the royal
family at the 2020 Baptists Sunday night
while presenting the best director award
the actresses joke was hilarious but
awkward because royal it's that this
royal palace plays yep Prince William
and Kate Middleton were sitting in the
audience it is really great to be here
at the Royal Andrew Royal Harry nice of
course the cats star was referencing
Prince Andrews connections to the late
Jeffrey Epstein the 59 year old recently
stepped down from royal duties amid
accusations which he's denying and his
unwillingness to speak with the FBI
regarding Epstein oh and speaking of
stepping down Brad couldn't be here
tonight due to family obligations so he
asked me to read his response for him
Brad Pitt threw in his own quip about
Prince Harry during his acceptance
speech which was read by co-star Margot
Robbie oh and he says that he is gonna
name this Harry cuz he is really excited
about bringing it back to the states
with him Gary's brother and
sister-in-law will and Kate unable to
contain their laughter after Brad's joke
about Harry and wife Megan Markel
recently losing their royal titles amid
their decision to split time between
Canada and the UK the Duke and Duchess
of Cambridge have been regular attendees
of the BAFTAs being that their royal
patrons and Will's been the president
for the past 10 years
we can always count on Kate to dazzle on
the red carpet and this year was no
exception the Duchess looked every bit
the future Queen in a recycled white and
gold Alexander McQueen gown which she
previously wore during the couple's 2012
trip to Malaysia all attendees were
asked to dress sustainably in
consideration of the environment
another thing rebel Wilson poked fun at
as Graham was saying tonight is all
about sustainability so I made this
dress by sewing two old dresses together
the red is from that one time I didn't
win Miss Australia and the black is from
a funeral I just went to for the feature
film cast to mess with the crazy lady
after the show Will and Kate chatted it
up with Hollywood a-listers like Renee
Zellweger Sam Mendes and Andy Serkis
[Music]